you're gonna start the form you're gonna
you want to try to do it energetically
it's going to help you physically okay
so what should I do first you're going
to help me what should I do before
release okay and that's going to do what
it's going to move my way to the midfoot
that's going to generate the taunted
field
so let's look at some of the ways that
I'm here
okay
my arms are close to my body
close and relaxed close and relaxed okay
no extreme wrist angles
relax
okay you're in that liminal State you
have an energetic value As you move and
you should not move till you get that
you try to keep it as much as possible
you try to keep it you let the body
get you to the mid foot you don't aim
for the mid foot you keep releasing
you'll get to the mid foot
down you go
boom
okay
here is another Preparatory
releasing Point there's many releasing
points
meaning many points in the form where
you generate
that energetic value and you reconcile
the two minds okay so the same thing
here as I come here
I'm going to release release release
there's no rush of when you start to
form we're doing it by command but I'm
giving you plenty of time okay
so I release my body
all tension free and you'll notice
something else okay
I'm going to sense that the shoulders
have drops
are going to stand for tension in the
legs and the glutes and the lower back
release all that you'll feel a swelling
in your abdomen
as it happens you'll feel the liminal
state of your mind
as you go
and because I can do this
my arms can be at this angle
with zero tension
you see the difference okay
just release
relax
put your hands
under your weapon
okay
you'll get into that liminal state
and just like when you were standing you
entered the liberal state of the two
minds being reconciled you try to carry
that into this position in this position
you reseat that liminal state
and you're going to try to carry that to
the next opportunity to regain the
liminal State okay so you don't snap out
of it and try to cut someone
but tactically this I don't do this in a
knife fight I don't stick things out
knife fighting you always go for what's
closest to you that means what's
furthest away from him
so you don't stick things out okay you
keep things close to you that way he has
to reach out to touch me and I can
defang his snake cut his thrust or his
slash
his leg you understand okay
so now as I go out and I do this form
you're not in a sword fight this none of
this makes any sense sword fighting
energetically it makes perfect sense so
as you go
you keep this same liberal state
there should not be any movement
in your body
in in fact tactically you're hiding the
fact that you're drawing you're not
trying to out draw him you're trying to
see how deep into the move you can get
before he senses you are actually
attacking okay do you understand that
difference okay so I do this with the
new deputies uh when we draw against
each other in certain training drills we
do
and uh one person will draw first and
then you try to beat them right
you can always beat them
by a great great deal if you don't freak
out and try to go your fastest on the
draw but you just move very casually
they can't sense it happening until
you're way too deep into the draw so you
always win it by a mile okay you can
even beat them
if they
Telegraph
their draw even though they're drawing
first you can beat them because you can
start when they start and if you have
smoother mechanics you're going to beat
them okay
so that's what you're doing here
marshalling
no
you see I'm flaring out the elbows my
eyes open my shoulders came up try to
enter the liminal state
everything's very subtle so look how my
hands are moving you see my hands moving
but look at my shoulders
not moving
you see that
now you're going I'm going to move my
hands I'll enter the liminal State
you're gonna look at my face
no change in my face my hands are moving
understand okay so that's what I'm
trying to do as I move don't
keep the liberal State the body moves
it's very calm out comes the sword boom
don't try for any power right now don't
try for any speed
try for this hiding of your intentions
okay
The Hiding of your intentions is
revealing that the you are in the
liminal state
so enter it you have two opportunities
to enter it
okay let's try it go
okay let's just get to here
so this this movement happens without
any meaning elsewhere
key telegraphing is shoulders
okay
so
if I
flare the right elbow
because I have an intention to swing
this sword and cut him down
you're going to Telegraph
he's going to see it
so you end up going
like this
you're now pulling the sword out
when you keep your elbow near your body
you're pushing the sword out
you see that
elbow flare
pulling the sword
has moving forward
pushing the sword
do you see that
this allows you should go wrong
you can thrust that Suka into the deep
okay
meeting if he reads my attention too
early I can bottle thrust forward I
can't do this like that
and very exposed I'm very mechanically
unsound
and I'm also exposed over here on the
ribs okay and I'm telegraphing
so this hand goes
this way
comes out
and into the person
uh Ronin
okay so we'll just do a drill
so you can appreciate it a little more
what you're doing okay I don't want you
to kill him this is not the Maya of the
form but I still I just want the drill
okay so I don't move anything I just
come out boom boom and push him over
that's all I'm doing
okay let's try it
so again you have a mental perception
it's it's delusional you're not
understanding knife fighting nor the
energetic component okay
again I don't want to stick things out
so you know for example that your sword
ends up from over here and then ends up
over here
and what you did is you pictured is like
a lightsaber cut
do that so you're moving your whole arm
from right to left that's all you can
figure out is how that gets there
but the principle of not telegraphing is
the more Dimensions you travel through
height width and depth the more
telegraphing you're doing
so at the beginning I'm trying to stay
in the sagittal plane only the depth
okay I don't want to give him any width
if I give him wit
he's gonna see it with the depth he's
gonna see it okay so
as I as I position The Sword in the
beginning
okay
I have this balance between I don't want
to move my hands a great deal
but I don't want this thing telegraphing
depth or width sorry okay so if I put it
over here
there I can stay in the same sagittal
plane on this point here to his body but
what do I have to do give with to get
over there do you see that so you have
to find this balance
as a general rule a general rule because
it depends on the length of your tsuka
so you can see matsuka is long
and the width of your tsuba is also is
different
the inner edge of your Suva is somewhere
in the area of halfway from your outer
rim and your spine your navel it's
somewhere in that area okay
to refine the area
I would enter the liminal State see
where my hands end up going as my body
positions itself and then move this
thing
over or outward as you need to in order
to not Telegraph or flare your elbow for
knife fighting tactics so this is too
far so I'll move it again
now my hands can touch it
okay without moving left or right my
hands can just come up and touch it okay
so
as I move and I come up
all I'm trying to do is have this sword
go as straight out as possible straight
out boom
so let's look at some of the things if
you come around to the front you'll see
remember your timing is always related
to space so from here I can't hit that
sternum
but as I move as I go up you're going to
see as I go up look what happened
it works okay
where did where did that space come from
my knees will go slightly in
so as I go you're gonna watch my knees
will go and see how they went in
you can't keep your knees out here and
come up like you want to energetically
my knees will go in
which is tactically sound in a knife
fight
shrink dude don't stick things out so
you straight fall back
and now I can get that thing to hit the
center line
I don't have things sticking out okay
as I hit him
don't let
the final destination of the sword make
you think that you're gonna make an arc
with this sword so you don't want to go
like this
don't want to do that
all I'm doing here is boom you're
getting
drill okay so let's try it again and
then we'll get to well how does my sword
get over there okay all right let's try
hey
chaining on your own
bring that into the nukes get
so the energetic values are going to be
your Marshall values so so far
by doing things energetically correct I
don't Telegraph
right okay
uh and not leaving targets out for a
knife fight I'm not flaring things you
see
uh if goes wrong oh I'm gonna hit
him in the chest you see I have a
contingency plan on deck which you
always have to marshally because
doesn't work okay
when I have the improper energetic
values elbows are flared so that's
targets are sticking out right I didn't
dominate the center line as I as early
as I could because I'm swinging my arm
out to the right that doesn't make sense
marshally and I'm telegraphing the high
Health which means it's only going to
work if I'm physically faster than that
person that doesn't make Marshall sense
okay
so same thing here if I do the form
energetically correctly I will marshally
do the form correctly there were a lot
of you
that sought your stance and then drew
the weapon
that makes no sense because you just
stuck your target out there
before you got your weapon out there
do you understand that doesn't make
sense that's like you you send your
troops onto the beach
and then you bomb the beach
no bomb the beach first and then send
your troops onto the beach okay so first
I'll demonstrate the mistake as you're
going along you're coming out and you go
like this and then you went like that
that the sword goes first The Stance
follows the sword okay that's all we're
looking at right now we still haven't
yet dealt with how does my sword go from
here to there okay so this sword goes
first that is one reason why you'll see
that my knees have to come in the sword
goes first The Stance follows the sword
okay
look at this energetically
the sword is Young energy it generates
space then I could do Ed me you don't do
eating me where there's no tsuki where
there's no opening for eating meat okay
so the sword creates the space boom and
then the sword follows that makes sense
in a knife fight if you stick your foot
out first right he shared he takes his
step wow cut the leg and that's it it's
done okay the sword has to leave you
never stick your foot in whether it's
three or four feet of steel or six
inches of Steel you don't do it okay all
right so let's get that right let's try
it
okay so again
if I'm doing it correctly energetically
so as I'm not telegraphing everything's
just relaxed and hanging I'm not
telegraphing out comes the sword you're
going to see my stand my feet come
together my knees they come closer
together they're not out in say
something they come closer together okay
how close do they come they come to my
hips
okay so if you rewind if you fast
forward the film I want my feet in
alignment with my hips
okay if my knees are out here
from seza
and I put my feet where my knees are is
that doesn't work so what what tends to
happen is you do things all weird and
sometimes you're you you fix it along
the way but it's fixed at the beginning
okay
so as my legs come out right I'm in
Cesar I got my two fists width there I
could my knees to come up nothing's
moving out comes the sword okay
the sword is going to create the yin
space for the ad mean so the sword goes
threat has moved back
that's when the foot comes in
okay that's when it's not part of my arm
trying to attack the guy
boom and then it moves into the space I
just cleared
what some markers on my hand will go
back
again I'm trying not to Telegraph
partially and I'm trying not to flex
energetically I'm trying not to Yang
Yong everything
so when I draw the sword on nukiskin my
hand never goes higher than the solar
plexus my hand does not go higher than
the solar plexus okay and because of the
angle that I'm trying to use where I
don't Telegraph meaning I don't flare
things and I don't travel through
multiple dimensions
you're going to say well just look at it
biomechanically if I have the hand at
the solar plexus
when I turn this hand over I don't even
raise the hand
just turning the hand over is going to
make this sword ascend
when I do that
I should have my fist
just under my shoulder that way I'm not
activating the outer deltoid which is
marginally inferior here it's down in my
lap still
my wrist will be flat my arms at a 45
degree angle okay that's too far you're
going to activate the outer deltoid too
high you're going to activate the outer
deltoid the sword is going to be weak
the kisaki you want it no further in
then as a guide the inner edge of your
Suba
you don't you want it also
at the height of the bottom edge of your
Suba
so when you draw
the way to get there
is don't do anything to the sword
don't lift it don't pull it out just
turn your wrist over
and it'll do it all okay so I'm coming
out there's solar plexus don't do
anything to the sort you're going to be
there just fine you got it you do
something to the sword things start
jacking up on you martially you're using
an inferior muscle group
Marshall Lee you're too far away from
the center line that you just dominated
okay if you're
where this Edge is there's an
orientation on the weapon back to the
center line it went that far because I
had to clear it for the edema but it's
ready to go again okay
all right so
to help me
get there
and to help me not do anything to the
sword you have to understand marshally
what's happening this is a very simple
strategy it's used all over the world
all throughout time it's a minor major
strategy
a jab cross is a minor major strategy
I'm not I'm the only thing I'm trying to
do with the jab is occupy him
okay
then boom I have the killing blow or The
Knockout blow in the nuke Escape here
the only thing I'm trying to do is
occupy him
foreign
got it okay
it's still gonna hurt just like the
stiff jab's Gonna Hurt okay it's not a
powder puff it's not a distraction right
the best way of distracting him mentally
is hurt him so he's still gonna hurt
okay
so but
you're not trying to cut his head off
your sword is not a lightsaber so you're
not swinging it
left to right
you're going to go over you're going to
go higher you're going to activate the
deltoid you're going to give up the
center line okay or you're going to wind
up for it at the beginning and Telegraph
the hell out of it okay
what you're doing instead is not not you
guys but I think it'll still work but
you got right I don't know three four
feet of of forged iron here right it
hurts it's a metal Club okay just lots
of fencing options boom they just hit
with the flat of the sword hit with the
back of the sword it hurts okay it's not
a lightsaber all the time so your first
thing is to just hit him with your metal
Club
not engine interested in did I
slice his head or anything like that
okay
so we're going to do it on his arm
we're gonna scoot him back
maybe a camera over on this side
the engine for this
is your wrist
my wrist was here
you see
and then at the end my wrist ended here
so let's rewind and watch my wrist
okay
is what my wrist is doing
dislike I'm here do it over here on the
side
my wrist is here
is what my wrist is doing okay
but
with the weapon
on a very vulnerable Target because it's
at the distal end of his spine and
there's a hinge at his neck and it has
stuff like his eyes and his nose and his
mouth there do you get it okay so when I
come out
the sword would be here boom I'm just
gonna hit him with that side of with the
steel that's my main goal
I'm not trying to go
okay
so we'll turn it to the Moon
don't move because this is live
and put your hands closer if you plug
okay
you'd be back here
and all you're going to do is flip the
wrist
that's it
only
here okay
so I'll push a little here
so you can feel it what your body want
to do
there's his kazushi you see
then that's where I come in whoa he's in
the kazushi he's in the Tilt that you're
always trying to generate in your
kihonawasa he's in the Tilt that's all I
need okay
so you're going to do that drill
in the drill you're gonna have to game
the nuke
have the moon out
and have the kisaki back by the Saya and
you work on pulling this flicking boom
and hitting with that thing okay let's
try it okay
so once you
flick
hit boom that's where you get that last
little
um sorry
okay did you feel it yeah okay so are
you going to hit it
boom on it right there and then your arm
has to go over here okay so you hit it
boom and you're gonna see that that
thing increase
his little impact point do you got it
and then I'm in that final spot
stay there where you were a little lower
you were okay and then I'm here then
I'll move up
and then I have the killing blood
so let's look at
the my laser concept
in a street fight orientation okay
I'm gonna Chop on this throat if you see
what it did to him it all did did he die
from it did it knock him out no but it
just just struck and that's where my
next shot comes in that's the same
concept you're doing in this technique
okay so it's gonna occupy him because it
hits
a hinge which is going to affect his
balance and it's affecting his breathing
do you see that and so just whatever
you're just here and let's add in no
expression no nothing boom do you see
how fast it comes because you detect it
later but I don't let the killing blow
the kitties hype me up everything's very
relaxed and then I turn it on on the
next shot okay let's try this okay talk
about what we just saw over there
this is how you guys were doing your
show Hotel on the on the miners Drive
you're over committing
you know off balance you went ahead and
threw it and you're way off balance okay
that's right you didn't do any damage
do you understand so he's going to
defend the second one
so the what makes it minor is that I'm
not seeking spinal displacement again I
said preoccupation that's what I'm
trying to do or you can think of it I
have uh taken the initiative he has to
not respond to my initiative okay that's
what you're trying to do so
there's nothing nothing no intention as
you can see
I didn't over commit I didn't commit at
all I could go backwards now to another
weapon do you think
okay
cool but now the hard part because the
rest of you were like okay I won't over
commit on the minor but now you under
commit on the major that's not correct
either do you that's do you understand
so this is all nothing but I can't go
like that
so this one hits and Boop
that's what you want your body is coming
in and totally taking the space that you
just generated okay
that would be I'm just showing you how
much my body's in the technique that
would be your boom that's what you hit
with that type right cross you
understand so you have to change the
Cadence
no the Cadence changes but it's not here
same Cadence it changes minor measures
whole body comes in you can see how
tight that is I even felt his chest on
my chest okay
killing knockout I want him on the
ground okay so let's try it again
if you've paid attention I can't
and he went before I actually touched
him
do you get it that means I Telegraph and
you can tell that that's coming but if I
just hear I do my energetic stuff he
can't do you feel that difference right
there's no he's looking as plain as me
okay what did you do you're gonna get
something at him so you relax but it's
not I'm relaxed it's PJ
okay there is a power in it right okay
but there's no tension in it no tension
I'm just forget that we're fighting I
just have a little physical puzzle okay
no tension no intention no desire and I
just move
you feel that difference okay you got it
all right so let's try that because
that's the nuked skin of shohakto okay
it has an effect
you take his balance right to gain the
initiative
but I can't Telegraph it
and to not Telegraph it I have to meet
the energetic values of
them okay let's try it again
okay so that this is equivalent of the
drawing drill we do in law enforcement
okay so I'm trying to hit her she's will
block it if she can or deviate whatever
she wants to do okay
now
biomechanically it should not be
possible for her to block it
because I'm moving first
okay
and she has to be reactionary but when
you Telegraph
she's not so much reactionary she has
plenty of time okay so this is the value
you'll learn in the nuked skin
everything is very relaxed and I moved
and she's gonna try to defend herself
see she got her hand up Lord I flex
relax
you'll never get it
do you guys see that okay so I know it
looks like they're faster if you move
your hand faster through space with
tension but not really not marginally
speaking marginally speaking you're
going to be subjectively faster which is
what counts
if she doesn't recognize the move till
later
okay got it all right here we go